this is I'm going to visit entertaining
jail Aiden what's going on guys Aiden
yeah I know him um hope everyone's
having a magnificent week day month Etc
2020 2023 is amazing so far for me it's
going by kind of fast though already
almost done with January which is insane
right
um I don't know if you guys saw what
happened today but
um Andrew Tate on his Twitter account
someone I think runs his account at 7am
La time made a tweet basically saying
um I'm allowing five people to visit me
in my uh basically visit me in jail uh
four of which are family members and the
fifth person is uh is Aiden me
oh man I woke up to that and I had it
just the biggest smile on my face I'm
like oh my God this is this is real this
is crazy
um you know I already told you guys I I
you know with Andrew
he took me in and uh you showed the
uttermost love and respect to myself and
my my peers around me and um he's never
given me weird creepy Vibes and he's
never you know never given me like the
shoulder in a way he's always just been
open arms and loving but yeah man I I've
been feeling amazing and just so happy
in life and um I wake up every day and
I'm just so grateful and appreciate me
thank for everything in my life and um
you know everyone's everyone is uh
expecting to see results and all that
stuff and and they want to see what's
going on and I'm putting in work every
day all you know in the gym and I'm
working on my mind and everything
um so I'm just letting y'all know right
now I'm I'm locked in
um and the answer to everyone's question
if I'm gonna basically uh go see Andrew
in jail because he did put me on his
visitation list uh the answer is uh this
educate I'm on my way
I will see you in Romania G ather
filming this podcast he's going to drive
to Romania why do you turn on the car
um I thought he was going to play like
the Tate song can you imagine the jail
phone podcast on Twitch like that is
number one twist stream of all time
that's gonna be enough that's my uh
exotic car I don't have a Bugatti that's
fantastic that one of the first things I
said is I wonder who's gonna get the the
jail interview and I we know nothing
about Romanian jail hopefully they'll
let cameras and cameras in and this can
actually happen yeah are you sure
they're going to do a stream I'm not
sure they're gonna do a stream but if
Aiden's going there he's 100 gonna try
to do it I don't know like what and also
he's got to be really careful his
lawyer's not going to want to do this
probably you don't know what Aiden's
gonna well we'll see we'll see bro
Hayden's got balls for going too because
like the fact that they're locking them
up with like no evidence and Aiden's
taking the risk to go out there yeah
I heard he might come to rumble really I
heard a chat I heard he might come to
rumble which if he's really about it
Aiden I'm telling you I know you saw my
tweet I think if you're really about to
be if you're shaving your head you're
all about self-improvement you know that
twitch promotes degeneracy have you seen
the girls on Twitch what they do oh
they they sit in hot tubs half naked and
then just taking money from Sims is
basically only fans light it's a funnel
for only kind of like it's like porn
like it's literally like like a what do
they call it like webcam foreign
and they got like two-day suspensions
but they got well the funny thing is I
got an argument with your rage about
this
um because Aiden got a seven-day ban
recently he's banned on twist right now
uh so I don't know when he's going to
Romania but he got a seven-day ban
because somebody ran in his GTA stream
dressed up as Hitler and which is dark
because if it was anybody else that
wouldn't have got you in trouble like
twitch twitch picks and choose what they
do you got a 70 band for that I think
it's really because he's associated with
agitate they're applying pressure some
GTA guy dresses Hitler was a big deal
but that's funny when you brought up a
girl had was uh having sex on Twitch she
got the same level band seven days for
having literal like porn on Twitch is
the same as someone a Hitler in GTA and
snico got banned and you never got
banned on Twitch and no one talks about
that I was banned on Twitch and nobody
knows why I didn't break any rules you
never streamed on Twitch before never
and they got me for band evasion and I
didn't say anything it was just because
of me so there's a very specific agenda
and my point is Aiden Ross if you really
care about this movement come over to
rumble that's where free speech is
really at that's where your fans are
going to start to wake up your fans are
not going to be involved in generacy
playing video games all day uh promoting
Behavior you know watching these
mindless people who talk about
absolutely nothing you don't have any
specific philosophy that's why I like
your videos because there's a specific
philosophy and a specific ideology that
you follow everybody on Twitch it's more
profitable if they don't the talking
heads on botsum and twitch they're
supposed to just have no point of view
so they'll never get banned it's
mindless entertainment so Aiden come
over to rumble
so the whole movement that you're that
you're talking about about free speech
and coming back is is actually going
back to the time that I grew up in like
where you can just say stuff you can
speak freely and people got offended and
that was where it ended you got offended
you moved on to something else you saw a
sneak oh sneako pisses me off I'm not
listening to snico anymore it was that
simple yeah I don't gotta ruin his life
and that's what this whole movement is
going to do it's gonna take us back to a
time of sanity and actual freedom of
speech so I'm all about it moving to
rumble what do you think is the biggest
shift in the way our Our Generation
operates in the way your generation
operated our feelings didn't run our
lives I knew you're going to say that
yeah right where we our feelings were
you know they matter to us personally we
dealt with stuff we did a lot of
stuffing things down but you know what
we made that makes you tougher we were
tougher we had a thicker skin somebody
said something it made us cry we went
and cried in private we came back out
with our chin up that was it we didn't
have to tell the whole world we didn't
need everybody to come defend us we
didn't need a protest we didn't need to
write a long diatribe on on the internet
about you know your feelings all of our
feelings and all of the implications of
our feelings like who cares
[Music]
gone
[Music]